Four years ago yesterday,
there was a shooting
at my younger sister Jenny's high school,
Saugus High School
in Santa Clarita, California.
Jenny was lucky enough to see kids running
when she was about to be dropped off
by her carpool, so she stayed safe,
but all of her friends
were placed on lockdown.
Kids I've watched grow up and have known
for as long as I can remember.
In the hours that followed,
parents waited at my city's Central Park
to reunite with their kids
as students were released
building by building,
escorted by police
and SWAT teams to the park.
Three days later, there was a vigil
at that same Central Park
to honor Gracie Muehlberger
and Dominic Blackwell,
whose parents laid them to rest
at the tender ages of 15 and 14.
It was the largest gathering
in my city's history.
Despite the divisions in my hometown,
we stood at peace
with one another that night,
yearning for a better future.
This very American tragedy
that we have had to witness
time and time again
speaks to a larger issue about democracy.
Like many people in the face of tragedy,
I wanted to do something.
And to do something,
to truly participate in democracy,
we have to acknowledge
that injustice is cyclical
and that any fight of a neighbor
is the fight of our own.
But how do we, wherever we may be,
with whatever tools we have,
fight that fight?
I've realized over the course
of growing up
that what we largely consider
to be participating in democracy
is honestly kind of narrow
and unimaginative.
We're taught that we can vote
and run for office,
which are both important,
but what about those of us
who can't because of our age,
our immigration status, our class,
not to mention the countless others
facing disenfranchisement
through voter suppression.
The truth is, any of us, of any age,
living in some semblance of a democracy
or striving towards it,
possess the tools to have a voice
in our governments and communities.
It's just a matter of learning
how to have agency with those tools.
For me, that's been coding
and social media.
It's unconventional,
but I found the most success
in having an influence
by using whatever's in front of me,
really tuning in to my networks
and communities,
meeting people where they're at
and centering joy and fun wherever I can.
And it works. Let me explain.
In the case of this school shooting,
the parents of Gracie Muehlberger
and Dominic Blackwell
began a push to have
the two of them memorialized
at the entrance of our Central Park.
To me and much of my community,
this memorial was a no-brainer.
To others, it was "grandiose
and highly inappropriate."
That's a direct quote, by the way.
And a number of local officials
agreed with them.
But that cannot and should not
nullify the needs and the wants
of the greater community.
So Gracie and Dominic's parents,
determined to properly
memorialize their children,
created a petition and organized efforts
to push our city council
to approve the memorial.
The petition got over 10,000 signatures
and people emailed the city in masses.
Eventually, they approved,
and we all thought we were done.
But, as it turns out,
the land that Central Park is on
is owned by the Santa Clarita Water Board.
So they have the final say.
And a committee created
to advise on that decision
penned a seven-page paper
on why they should actually
reject the memorial.
And we didn't even know about this
or know this was still up for debate
until the day they were
supposed to vote on it.
I was so unbelievably angry.
How is it that the community
can come together, organize
and finally get a win
just for it to be rendered fruitless
by a vocal minority with fancy titles?
I wasn't having it,
but I still felt powerless.
I wasn't on the committee.
I wasn't an elected official.
I couldn't even tell you
what a water board did.
But, like I said,
I had these two sources of power:
coding and social media.
You may be thinking, "Girl, like, OK."
(Laughter)
But follow me here, follow me here.
I learned to code when I was 15
at a Kode With Klossy summer program,
where I learned
that I could apply that skill
to anything and everything.
And on the content side of things,
I got bored during the pandemic
and loved giving my unsolicited opinion
and yelling on the internet,
so I got a pretty sizable
following on TikTok
and joined the organization
Gen-Z for Change,
and posting content
to mobilize my generation
to vote in the 2020 election.
So I knew that with these
two powers I held,
I could do something.
I could make something real
in the three or so hours I had.
So I got to work.
I found an email address
where people could send
public comments on agenda items
and coded a tool where people
could just put in their name,
affiliation, anything else
they wanted to send,
and a randomly generated
email would be created.
All they had to do was push "send."
I finished it like 15 minutes
before the deadline,
it was one of the ugliest websites
I had ever made.
(Laughter)
I posted it to Instagram,
Twitter, TikTok --
I had around 150,000
followers at the time.
I sent it to my family.
My sister sent it to her friends
who sent to their friends,
and then I held my breath.
A few hours later, the water board voted
9 to 3 to approve the memorial,
and I felt at ease.
It wasn't until
a few months later, though,
that I learned that out of
the 63 comments submitted,
56, the vast majority, were sent
using the tool that I had coded.
(Applause)
Which is so insane
because there was so little time
people were able to use it
in the first place.
This success was a testament to the fact
that so often people want to speak out.
They want to do something
but don't know how
or get discouraged
in the face of bureaucracy.
Making it a little bit easier for folks
needs to be a core value for all of us.
In another instance,
Virginia Governor Glenn Youngkin
created a tipline
to report critical race theory
being taught in schools.
I had a problem with that.
So I wanted there to be an easy,
fun, community-oriented way
to get this tipline taken down
as soon as possible.
So I coded a tool that allowed people
to send song lyrics and lines
from The Bee Movie to the tipline.
(Laughter)
Essentially, it takes the name
of a real school, a real city in Virginia,
and spits out a very ridiculous report.
For example, "I have reason to believe
Thomas Jefferson High School
is teaching race.
I overheard a teacher saying,
'Shawty had them
apple bottom jeans (jeans).'"
(Laughter)
Yeah, it's silly, it's goofy.
It's just as unserious as the creation
of a teacher-reporting tipline itself,
which is exactly what draws people
to this kind of action.
Democracy is just more fun and inviting
when you take it into your own hands.
After I finished the website,
I sent it to my friends
at Gen-Z for Change.
We all posted videos.
Thousands of emails were sent
from every state in the country
and virtually every continent,
and we had emails bouncing
within 48 hours.
Months later, the tipline
was quietly officially shut down.
Didn't even last a year.
Because of the skills of a few,
the platforms of many
and the will of hundreds
of thousands of meddling kids
unified in our intolerance of injustice,
we were far more powerful
than a couple people
in official positions of power.
Now, I'm not asking y'all
to drop everything and learn how to code,
even though I definitely think you should.
Coding is part of my power, right?
But power manifests differently
to different people.
If you have a pen, write something.
If you have an instrument, play something.
If you have the anger of a thousand suns
and disposable income,
open your purse.
(Laughter)
And if you have social media
and a smartphone --
I know that y'all do, so don't try me --
tell a story, and let it
spread like wildfire.
And while it's true
that a subset of people use their skills
for hateful, nefarious,
less-than-democratic purposes,
the sheer existence of this subset
requires that we think
of more innovative and creative ways
to ensure that the voices of the masses
are genuinely heard and accounted for.
Now, every time I'm home
and I walk by Central Park,
and see the new signage,
I'm reminded of the power, our anguish,
our joy, our stories,
and our unity holds.
We were able to change my community
forever and for the better,
all by causing a ruckus on the internet.
The stability of democracy internationally
requires that we use
whatever skills and resources we have
to combat hate, bring movements to life
and stand united
in solidarity with one another
on every corner of the globe.
Justice can't wait,
so take what's in front of you,
get really creative and cause a ruckus.
(Applause)